[Music]
a question for us
joshua mentioned that he doesn't have
internet at home how is this possible in
today's hyper-connected world
i don't have internet at home that is
true
i think one can live without internet
altogether sure it seems less practical
that seems like a more ascetic response
yeah but there are times throughout your
day that you don't have the internet it
just happens to be my part of my day is
a bit longer danny experienced this this
weekend um he on saturday had a
screenless saturday oh
an accidental screenless saturday on
purpose oh nice yeah they said he and
amy set their phones in a drawer and
just went out to malibu hung out on the
beach spent time together yeah and he
said i felt like i was being heard
yeah for the first time yeah that's
awesome man she felt like she was being
heard yeah and well why is that because
we've removed that distraction
at home there are three things that i
don't have right now we've moved into
this new house one is i don't have home
internet which also means i don't have
wi-fi if i ever did get home internet i
would never get wi-fi again
and if i find that it's absolutely
essential to have home internet it would
be a wired connection and there's a
reason for that i don't want the electro
smog associated with the wi-fi and my
home and i know it disrupts my wife's
sleep it doesn't really mess with mine
that much but if you turn on a wi-fi
router it really screws up personally
and so a lot of people are very
sensitive to dirty electricity yeah
right and wi-fi is part of that
obviously cell towers can be part of it
just regular electricity and your walls
are a part of that as well yeah it's
unavoidable but we i want to minimize it
it's one of the reasons we moved or
removed it has less electro smog
and so into that dirty electricity oh
yeah
give me some of that dirty electricity
oh it's so dirty
and so
no we don't have
internet at home we also don't have a
television at home and
yes do i enjoy some shows from time to
time yeah but now we have to find a way
around that or going to a movie theater
or downloading something onto a laptop
and watching it that way it's injecting
some friction into our lives so no home
internet that's some serious friction
right because i don't have instant
access in fact there's not a cell tower
close by to where we live so i don't i
get one bar of service if i'm lucky in
certain parts of my house so forget
about trying to tether to your phone not
possible where i live but the third
thing i don't have at home is a phone a
cell phone
meaning throughout my house i don't
bring my phone with me we have the
entryway rule so i walk into the home
and i set the phone and on this counter
in the entryway and that's where it goes
that's where it charges that's where it
stays i have access to it i can go walk
over there i can respond to a text
message but it doesn't give people
immediate 100 access to me throughout
all of my waking hours
and so how do you do that by being more
deliberate with how you need to use
these tools whether it's the internet
now i have to go somewhere whether it's
into an office to a coffee shop
to a friend's house to a library
whatever it might be and i'm now
focusing not on surfing the net but
deliberately using the internet to
accomplish whatever i want to accomplish
but you know what it does not having
internet cause i did this for five years
once right i didn't have home internet
for five years
and it was the most productive five
years of my life yeah you and i
published four books during that period
of time we started the minimalist
podcast we made our first documentary
we started going out on tours
and
it made me hyper focused it's not that i
didn't have access to internet it's i
removed it from the place where i
felt most compelled to just surf for a
little while i'll just waste a little
time oh just for a minute and all of a
sudden i look up and it's been an hour
and 45 minutes and i've been on
instagram looking at
butts and
and more butts yeah and fast cars right
and it's like well what am i doing here
i don't
this isn't serving the greater good for
me so i've removed that distraction i've
added some friction
has allowed me to produce creative
traction
in my life and the same is true with tv
the same is true with a foam what are
the things i can remove that adds a
little bit of discomfort to my life that
ultimately makes my life more meaningful
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100 percent
advertisement free